mais d'abord on prend donc la direction
de l'ehpad depuis gibeau à loches
considéré comme le premier cluster
d'indre et loire
vendredi nous vous annoncions que 121
cas positifs au co vie de 19 avaient été
recensés sur place aujourd'hui la rs
annonce que dix seniors ils sont décédés
plus d'explications dans ce reportage de
florent clavel dix résidents décédé
l'ehpad de loches paix l'un des plus
lourds tributs depuis le début de
l'épidémie
trois premiers cas ont été détectés le
mois dernier immédiatement les visites
ont été interdites et les 205 résidents
isolés dans leur chambre
mais l'épidémie a continué de flamber à
ce jour 133 résidents positif ainsi que
46 agents la situation évidemment
préoccupante
l' agence régionale de santé tandis un
très étroit évidemment avec la
directrice de l'établissement qui je
rappelle est un établissement son allié
de loges vous même en direction partagée
avec le centre hospitalier régional
universitaire de tours donc par rapport
notamment à des aides médicales qui
peuvent être apportées çà c'est un c'est
un plus indéniable
on constate que quand l'établissement un
établissement est chez quand bien même
ils ferment en effet son établissement
aux visites
quand bien même des mesures beaucoup
plus drastiques sont prises et elles le
sont dans la très grande majorité des
cas le virus peut diffuser et c'est vrai
que personnes vulnérables sont parmi les
premières à être vecteur de ce virus et
ça peut aller très vite
et l'exemple malheureusement de l'ehpad
et puis gibeau de loches en est en un
résident sont aujourd'hui en
surveillance rapprochée
les familles sont tenus informés chaque
semaine l'hôpital de loches dont
dépendent les pattes depuis gibeau n'a
pas souhaité répondre à nos questions
mais une conférence de presse est
annoncée après demain